we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p we
haven't heard from the egg man for a
little bit but he had very strong
comments about a new advertiser on the
david pakman show take a listen yeah I'd
like to place an order for the family
pack of omaha steaks for 4995 but i
wanna get extra extra cow Dave how many
people sweat you over that Omaha victim
are salt I love it I eat meat fair's
fair you li get what you felt so good
for you but I do I say welcome back
though man and i'ma hope you're feeling
better welcome back at work all gave
some of a bounce about the ohon basis if
everybody you get so many we decided
makeup can buck in this world okay
please add and uh I'm glad you're back
fell over brother alright so great to
hear from the egg man is always yes the
Eggman is referring to a new advertiser
on the David Pakman show Omaha Steaks we
actually have this month and in October
also we have a number of new advertisers
this is really really good for the David
Pakman show as you know advertisers have
always made up a tiny tiny portion of
the revenue that we have mostly we have
membership as our primary source of
revenue and then of course we have our
youtube partnership and our amazon
affiliate of a situation etcetera it's
really great that the program has
actually gotten big enough such that we
are getting more advertisers and I turn
down advertisers i would say at this
point on Anna every other week basis
we've had a bunch of pitches for uh of
supplements with uh you know the
advertiser wants me to make completely
non evidence-based claims about what the
supplement does I wouldn't even consider
doing something like that and I've
completely rejected those out of hand we
are hand picking the advertisers and
fortunately because of support from our
members who get commercial free versions
of the show anyway and they're not
really uh impacted by these ads because
of that I can turn down any advertiser
that I want to and I do that regularly
and I will continue to do it so
hopefully most people have the
perspective of the eggman which is hey
this is a program that is
self-sustaining
and we are going to make careful but
also realistic decisions about saying
yes or no to advertisers alright today
on the bonus show I will introduce you
to new david pakman show producer hat
that is on today's bonus show i will
also tell you about the cost of Wi-Fi
for journalists at the first
presidential debate and 911 calls
related to the presidential debate david
pakman.com slash membership that's the
one place where you can sign up for
instant access to the bonus show